now Greenland's ice sheet is melting at
an alarming rate seven times faster than
in the 1990s new analysis of satellite
data shows it's losing about 250 billion
tons of ice every year and the losses
are continuing to accelerate since 1992
meltwater from Greenland has raised
global sea levels by one centimeter and
that puts millions more people at risk
from flooding well let's speak now to
Andrew Shepherd who's a professor of
Earth Observation at the University of
Leeds and was the lead one of the lead
authors of that study and he joins us
now on skype from Leeds professor let's
start with the rate of ice loss here
because it's not just the fact that the
ice is melting it's that it's melting
much much faster than we thought it
would right so now what we thought was
the worst case scenario is actually the
middle-of-the-road scenario now we need
a worst-case scenario a new one that's
correct it takes a long time to collect
enough measurements to be able to check
climate model predictions but now we
have two or three decades and it's
really clear that the course that
Greenland and in fact Antarctica as well
are following is the worst case scenario
so that means more sea level rise than
people are expecting and what's driving
all of this ice rust so in Greenland
it's two things it's the the air around
the ice sheet is too warm and it's
melting ice from the surface and the
ocean around the altitude is too warm
and that's causing the Gracias which
carve icebergs into the sea to flow more
quickly let's also talk about impacts
here because we've run through some
numbers but by my understanding the loss
of the Greenland ice sheet doesn't just
mean sea level rise but it could also
increase global warming fairly
dramatically because of the release of
methane from the melted earth and then
less heat being reflected from the Sun
back into space when there's no snow so
when you put all of this together are we
approaching a tipping point here tipping
points are interesting things for people
to speculate about but I think the story
that we're trying to tell people today
is that this is a predicted climate
change and this will still have a
serious impact on a large number of
people just the regular melting of the
Greenland ice sheet we don't need to
invoke invoke potential situations like
tipping points and this is happening now
and we do need to do something about it
as we were saying this is also happening
much more quickly than we expected so
what's the reason for the conservatism
and the science and the reports over the
years that's led to this point so the
science actually hasn't been
conservative it's always presented
regular and the lower and a worst case
scenario but the I guess the politicians
have chosen to favor the mid mid
scenario and not the worst case the
polar ice sheets it's the latter and
that has big consequences for sea level
we've been talking about sea level rise
but could this also have consequences
for weather patterns and potential more
extreme weather events around the world
so these things are all related to one
another and in fact it is those extreme
weather events coupled with sea level
rise which are going to cause the
flooding it's not it's not the steady
increase in sea level around the world
that will eventually inundate very
low-lying areas so what happens when we
get storms in winter just before winter
in autumn and those surges they're
manageable now they only flood our
coastal regions once every few years but
it will become much more frequent in the
future well you've been studying this
now for years and this week leaders are
meeting in Madrid are you optimistic
that we as humanity are going to be able
to come together and face this crisis in
time I always think it's important to
retain hope but Greta Kinberg said this
morning at the coffe meeting she asked
where the leaders and it's true where
are the leaders in the UK we have an
election right now and our prime
minister is the only person who refused
to participate in the climate change
debate his plan for for our country is
to build more roads but that's exactly
the opposite thing that we need and so
going forward I guess we're all going to
have to try to hold on to what hope we
have thank you for joining us and you
shared you never see of Leeds thank you